Bill Maher has gotten himself in trouble
with the left yet again for a monologue
he delivers and he's being accused
because of this what you're about to
hear because of these remarks he's being
accused of um of white supremacy and and
actually justifying slavery but let's
listen and find out if that is a fair
characterization did Columbus commit
atrocities of course but people back
then were generally atrocious
everybody who could afford one had a
slave including people of color
the way people talk about slavery these
days you'd think it was a uniquely
American thing that we invented in 1619
but slavery throughout history has been
the rule not the exception the Holy
Bible is practically an owner's manual
for slaveholders putting aside the dig
at the Bible there which is silly and
not true the rest of it I basically
agree with and it's also not true that
people back in in earlier times were
generally atrocious it's not like they
weren't worse people but they lived in a
different time